10 de abril de 1998 el acuerdo del
viernes santo- pone fin al conflicto en
irlanda del norte
los enfrentamientos entre los unionistas
protestantes junto al ejército británico
por un lado y los republicanos católicos
por otros se sucedieron durante tres
décadas un conflicto territorial y
religioso que tiene sus raíces en la
partición de irlanda en 1921 cuando seis
condados del norte de la isla
permanecieron dentro del reino unido- en
la actualidad los dos millones de
habitantes de irlanda del norte están
divididos casi a partes iguales entre
católicos y protestantes el 30 de enero
de 1972 sucedió el domingo sangriento
cuando los soldados británicos abrieron
fuego contra una manifestación en derry
matando a 14 personas convirtiéndose en
un símbolo de la causa republicana
norirlandesa el ir a el ejército
republicano irlandés se embarcó entonces
en un ciclo de violencia y ataques como
sus enemigos unionistas no fue hasta los
acuerdos de 1998 cuando el sinn fein la
rama política del irá comenzó a jugar el
juego democrático dentro de la nueva
asamblea de belfast en 2005 el ira
acabaría abandonando oficialmente las
armas
dos años después junto al partido
unionista democrático dup el sinn fein
participó por primera vez en el
ejecutivo de irlanda del norte en la
persona del antiguo líder del ira martin
mcguinness los partidarios del
permanecer dentro del reino unido han
sido la primera fuerza política hasta
2022 pero el break sheet ha socavado
esta nueva paz porque el acuerdo del
viernes santo- prohíbe cualquier
frontera física entre irlanda e irlanda
del norte y con el break city se puso en
duda los europeos prevén el control
aduanero de las mercancías que pasan
entre irlanda del norte y el resto del
reino unido un protocolo que ha sido muy
criticado por londres y los unionistas
hasta el día de hoy y que ha provocado
graves trastornos de la cadena
suministros de irlanda del norte los
precios se dispararon y la sensación de
estar abandonados creció entre la
población en la primavera de 2021 los
barrios protestantes estaban en llamas y
hubo enfrentamientos entre algunos
jóvenes y la policía una señal de que el
conflicto sigue vivo en la mente de la
gente en belfast los muros sirven
separando a los republicanos católicos y
a los unionistas protestantes